>>> ABORTION RIGHTS AND GUN
CONTROL HA QUICKLY BECOME TWO
KEY ISSU FOR VOTERS AHEAD OF
THE MIDTERMS THIS FALL, AND THAT
COULD IMPACT VOTERS IN WL
EDUCATED SUBURBAN SWING
DISTRICTS.
MANY REPUBLICANS ARE BANKING ON
OTHER ISSUES LIKE RECORD HIGH
INFLATION TO HELP FLIP THE HOUSE
IN NOVEMBER.
>> JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS ALL
OF THIS, WE HAVE CNN POLITICAL
ANALYST, AND SENIOR EDITOR OF
THE ATLANTIC, RON BROWNSTEIN,
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST AND FORMER
SENIOR AIDE FOR THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN, ADRIENNE ELROD, AND
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST ALICE
STEWART.
GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU.
RON, ARE YOU SEEING EVIDENCE
THAT GUN SAFETY ABORTION HAVE
CHANGED THE EQUATION FOR THE
MIDTERMS?
>> I THINK THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER THEY WILL CHANGE THE
EQUATION.
I MEAN, THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
WHITE COLLAR SUBURBAN AREAS
WHICH TEND TO TAKE LIBERAL
POSITIONS ON GUN CONTROL AND
ABORTION WERE AT THE ABSOLUTE
CENTER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
TAKEOVER OF THE HOUSE IN 2018.
THEY WERE INDISPENSABLE TO
BIDEN'S VICTORY IN 2020, PLACES
FROM PHILADELPHIA AND DETROIT,
ATLANTA, PHOENIX, ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY WE SAW WHITE COLLAR
SUBURBS PROVIDED UNPRECEDENTED
MARGINS FOR DEMOCRATS.
REPUBLICANS ARE OPTIMISTIC
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO CLAW
BACK SOME OF THOSE DEMOCRATIC
GAINS AROUND THE ISSUE OF
INFLATION AND GAS PRICES AND
DISSATISFACTION WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, BUT NOW WE HAVE
THESE MOMENTOUS AND TRAGIC
EVENTS, THE SHOOTINGS IN BUFFALO
AND IN TEXAS, THE LEAKING OF THE
SCOTUS DRAFT MAJORITY OPINION
THAT HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
OVERTURN ROE.
WE HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO CHANGE
THE ISSUE MIX, I THINK
OPERATIVES ON BOTH SIDES AGREE
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT THESE
ARE THE QUESTIONS, ABORTION
RIGHTS AND GUN SAFETY THAT
VOTERS ARE THINKING ABOUT IN
THESE WHITE COLLAR DISTRICTS, IT
PROBABLY OFFERS DEMOCRATS THEIR
BEST CHANCE TO BLUNT THE WAVE
THAT REPUBLICANS THINK HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPING FOR THEM.
>> LET'S SEPARATE THE QUESTIONS,
THOUGH, BETWEEN IF IT WILL RISE
TO THE TOP OR NEAR THE TOP OF
THE ISSUES THAT VOTERS CHOOSE AS
THEIR TOP CONCERNS, AND HOW MUCH
WILL IT IMPACT.
ALICE, LET ME COME TO YOU, AND
RON LAYS OUT THE STATS ON HIS
LATEST PIECE ON CNN.COM, CLOSE
TO 7 OUT OF 10 COLLEGE EDUCATED
VOTERS DO NOT SUPPORT
OVERTURNING ROE.
CLOSE TO 9 OUT OF 10 SUPPORT
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS TO
BUY A GUN.
HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK MAYBE
INACTION ON THESE TWO ISSUES
WILL COST REPUBLICANS IN
NOVEMBER?
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A
WASH ON BOTH SIDES FOR THIS
REASON, VICTOR, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE ISSUE OF ABORTION AND GUN
CONTROL, THOSE ARE VERY DIVISIVE
ISSUES, VERY COMBATIVE ISSUES,
AND PEOPLE ARE VERY OPINIONATED
ON THIS, AND WHAT I EXPECT AND
WHAT I'M HEARING IS THIS IS
GALVANIZING PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES, THOSE THAT ARE PRO LIFE
ARE WORKING RIGHT NOW.
I KNOW THEY ARE TRAINING
VOLUNTEERS AND WORKING TO GET
OUT THE VOTE LATER THIS SUMMER
AND AS WE GET CLOSER TO
NOVEMBER, AND THOSE THAT ARE PRO
CHOICE ARE DOING THE SAME.
THE SAME WHEN IT COMES TO GUN
CONTROL ISSUES, PEOPLE THAT
PROTECT RIGHTS ARE GOING TO BE
OUT THERE TO PROTECT AS WELL AS
THOSE WHO WANT STRICTER GUN
CONTROL LAWS.
BUT THE KEY MOTIVATING FACTOR AS
WE OFTEN SEE IS INFLATION AND
ECONOMIC ISSUES.
THAT IS ONE AS YOU JUST STATED
IN THE LAST SEGMENT ALMOST HALF
OF AMERICANS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
INFLATION AND THE ECONOMY, THAT
IS GOING TO BE A BIG FACTOR AS
WE HEAD INTO THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE KEY ISSUES
RIGHT NOW, I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE
HAVE PROGRESS WHEN IT COMES TO
GUN VIOLENCE, AND THAT RIGHT
THERE I THINK WILL GO A LONG WAY
TO MAKING VOTERS CERTAINLY A LOT
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS CAN DO IN A
BIPARTISAN NATURE IN WASHINGTON.
>> TO ALICE'S POINT, VOTERS SEEM
MORE ENERGIZED OR GALVANIZED
THAN THEY WERE A MONTH AGO.
VERY OR EXTREMELY ENTHUSIASTIC
TO VOTE IN THE MIDTERMS.
A MONTH AGO, 36% OF DEMOCRATED
SAID, YES, THEY FELT EXTREMELY
ENTHUSIASTIC, NOW 43%.
A MONTH AGO, 47% OF REPUBLICANS
SAID THEY FELT EXTREMELY
ENTHUSIASTIC, NOW IT'S 56%.
IT IS WORKING ON BOTH SIDES.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS.
>> ON THIS ONE I'M GOING TO
SLIGHTLY DISAGREE BECAUSE THE
NUMBERS ARE ON THE SIDE OF
DEMOCRATS, WHEN YOU'VE GOT
UPWARDS OF 90% OF PEOPLE IN
AMERICA SUPPORTING BACKGROUND
CHECKS, 92% SUPPORT RED FLAG
LAWS AND ON THE ISSUE OF ROE,
UPWARDS OF BETWEEN 70 AND 80% OF
AMERICANS SUPPORT KEEPING ROE
THE LAW OF THE LAND.
THERE'S A LOT OF REPUBLICANS IN
THOSE NUMBERS.
ULTIMATELY, YES, I AGREE THERE'S
ENTHUSIASM ON BOTH SIDES, BUT
ULTIMATELY THE NUMBERS ARE ON
THE SIDE OF DEMOCRATS.
ANYTIME THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
CONTROL, ONE PARTY HAS CONTROL
OF THE WHITE HOUSE, SENATE AND
HOUSE, IT DOES MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THAT PARTY TO
MAINTAIN CONTROL GOING INTO THE
MIDTERMS.
JUST HISTORICALLY THAT'S BEEN A
CHALLENGE, BUT, YOU KNOW, I
THINK THE GOAL IS TO HELP
MITIGATE THE LOSSES AND IN THE
SENATE, KEY RACES FROM GEORGIA,
ROE AND GUNS ARE TWO ISSUES
SUBURBAN DEMOCRATS WILL BE
FOCUSED ON GOING INTO THE
MIDTERMS.
>> BASED ON SOME OF THE LATEST
REPORTING WE HAVE FROM MANU RAJU
THAT SENATOR MURPHY SAYS THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO BE AT THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE ON GUNS
FOREVER, AND CHUCK SCHUMER COULD
CALL A VOTE NEXT WEEK ON SOME
CHANGES.
WHAT'S THE WISDOM OF CALLING THE
VOTE, OR ANNOUNCING YOU'RE GOING
TO CALL THE VOTE AS NEGOTIATIONS
GO ON.
IS THIS GOING TO BE ANOTHER ONE
OF THE VOTES THAT DEMOCRATS KNOW
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET THE
VOTES HEADING INTO IT?
WE'VE SEEN IT SO MANY TIMES.
>> YEAH, LOOK, I THINK THERE ARE
CERTAINLY SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
CHUCK SCHUMER SAYING HE'S NOT
GOING TO CALL A VOTE INITIALLY,
AND CHANGING COURSE SAYING
ACTUALLY I THINK WE WILL CALL A
VOTE.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO LET THE
NEGOTIATIONS TAKE PLACE.
SENATOR MURPHY IS WORKING
CLOSELY, JOHN CORNYN IS
REPRESENTING REPUBLICANS AT THE
TABLE, SO THEY ARE QUIETLY
TRYING TO GET SOMETHING DONE.
I THINK THEY'RE ASKING FOR SPACE
AND SO THAT THEY CAN TRY TO GET
SOMEBODY TO COME TO THE TABLE.
I THINK SCHUMER SAYING THERE
COULD BE A VOTE NEXT WEEK IS HIS
WAY OF PUSHING THE BALL FORWARD.
I THINK THERE'S SO MUCH AT STAKE
HERE, AND I'M NOT SURE WE CAN
AFFORD TO CALL DEMOCRATS TO THE
FLOOR WITHOUT ACTUALLY HAVING
THE REAL NEGOTIATIONS.
I THINK WE'RE GETTING CLOSE, AND
I CERTAINLY CHOOSE TO BE
CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC ON THIS
ONE.
>> ALICE, WE ONLY HAVE TEN
SECONDS, DO YOU THINK
SOMETHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN THIS
TIME?
>> I DO.
I'M HEARING FROM REPUBLICANS,
THEY DO SEE THIS AS A TIME TO
TAKE ACTION.
AND THE FACT THAT CORNYN HAS THE
TASK TO LEAD THIS, AND IT IS AN
IMPERATIVE TIME AND WE DO NEED
TO TAKE ACTION, I DO SEE SOME
CHANGE.
IT DOES NOT NEED TO ONLY FOCUS
ON ONE ASPECT.
THIS IS A VERY COMPLICATED ISSUE
THAT NEEDS A COMPLICATED
SOLUTION AND IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
LOOKING AT GUNS BUT ALSO MENTA